hey guys uh my name is channing um my
boyfriend and i are both true babies
hell yeah dude huge fans of both of you
oh um
so
we're both gonna be going to therapy
soon
not together just separately good
i've always appreciated the fact that
both of you are very open about
going to therapy and seeking help
um it's not a thing a lot of you know
young men do i guess that's right now so
i'm just wondering if you have any words
of wisdom or
helpful advice for
people just taking that leap and
starting to go in that direction
all right love you guys bye i kind of do
i think there's there's one thing that i
i think i think when you go to therapy
it's a common thing to be like
i'm not gonna be defensive i'm gonna
like i'm gonna like go along with it and
like be open to the [ __ ] and whatever
the [ __ ] and be like if they say
something that i don't agree with i'm
gonna think about it and listen and like
sometimes
you you know you better than your new
therapist okay so sometimes it's okay to
be like no no no so i'm gonna stop you
there
[ __ ] no
you're just wrong about me
just [ __ ] no and i'm not being
defensive but you're wrong
okay do you say you're wrong to your
therapist have you said you're wrong to
therapist a lot well no that's you just
say like i know i don't think no like
yeah like nah i mean i know what you're
saying but like i i that's really not
where i'm coming from yeah and what
would your therapist say
she go she just go like this
no she would just she just says okay oh
i mean like well that's good she says
okay i don't know what she's thinking
right right she goes like this okay
all right i mean you know it could be
that in her mind but to her credit she
at least acts like she hears me and
believes me you know first of all
there's a lot of bad therapists out
there yes that see yeah do you know why
there's a lot of bad everything at every
job out there so true yeah i mean think
about how many [ __ ] bad
really the only job where everybody is
pretty good is sports player yeah
because it's a true meritocracy right
meritocracy true and i know what that
word means what does it mean yeah for
about sports
so it's whoever gets the most merit is
the best well yeah but yes got out of
that one but you don't know what that
means no i do and i do if you're like me
i go to therapist and i just think okay
this is a great therapist like i just go
in and i think that and then it takes me
a few weeks i'm like wait a second i
don't know like i went to one therapy i
do need a few weeks regardless you do
need a few weeks but i went to one
therapist that said
[ __ ] nothing
he actually didn't use his voice pretty
much nothing whoa really almost it was
like dr wall like he just [ __ ] it was
like i was speaking a monologue in a
play a bad with a bad audience do you
think this was a strategy or yes it was
that it was like a fruity and [ __ ]
fruit freudian yeah yeah it was like a
fruity and um yeah uh uh the branch
davidian people say floridian slip
yeah when they're saying it wrong froity
fraud fluidity and slip could be
mistaken as a freudian slip freudian
slip freudian like sigmund [ __ ] i
know sigmund freud the what's where it
comes from but when you [ __ ] make it
a whole different word you you like
gotta like
flower it up when you're wanting to be
wrong yeah fruity and slipped dying he's
dying freudian slip
freudian slip freudian because his name
is freudian say this word
c-h-o-r-c-o-a-l
c-h-o-r-c say it again why don't
you draw with it
c-h-o-r-c
chork
you know what i'm spelling right
c-h-a-r-a-r
c-o-a-l
charcoal [ __ ] right
charcoal
people what because people will be like
charcoal okay well you're not talking
about emphasis you're talking about the
actual wrong [ __ ] [ __ ] word let me
try to think about this in a [ __ ]
different way dude okay
whatever dude it's fruity it's
definitely whatever but it's freudian
and so anyway freudian okay so what was
i telling you oh yeah it's a freudian
[ __ ] way to do it is to just [ __ ]
sit back and let the person talk that's
what my other therapist yeah okay yes
that okay yeah
and i'm talking to this guy and i'm
doing it in the [ __ ] freudian way
yeah
for wittian fruity i mean fruity sounds
cooler yeah it's just not the way it is
so anyway i can't say words just how
they would sound cooler because then no
one would understand each other
you knew what i meant [ __ ] was going
to a lot of therapists i did that one
and then i did another one that was uh
bio what was it [ __ ] that
bio biodome no with polyamory [ __ ]
stephen it was with charlie probably
sure charlie short
dude i don't remember what it was what
did it do like what did you do he it was
for my ocd and he was like he was giving
me all sorts of uh
ways to combat my ocd
and one of the ways was have you ever he
was like what about the who cares
technique oh and i was like what and he
was like so if you don't say if you
don't close the door right your family's
gonna die in a plane crash and i was
like
i'm with you so far speaking my language
and he was like
who cares
[Music]
the worst doctor
swear to god swear to god that's what he
said and i was like oh okay
and then he was like that's the
silhouette technique and that was about
the last time i saw him yeah
that is um a therapist that i i stopped
seeing so make sure you get the right
therapist what i'm saying i do think
it's great that you're both going to see
therapists individually yes and not
together first
because you've got to figure out what
the [ __ ] root of the [ __ ] is and the
root of the [ __ ] starts with you and for
him the root of the [ __ ] starts with him
so coming together after that would be
great with all the tools that you
learned the therapy i made the biggest
mistake one time i was dating somebody
and i [ __ ] all over the couch
and then i said who cares and then she
had a therapist for many years and we
wanted to go to couples therapy at one
point and we were like let's try going
she was like let's try going to my third
oh and i and i went and i was like all
right this would be great every
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ]
thing that came up she was right and i
needed to do this or that of that of
that and i was like
could you can you at least pretend to be
an optimized [ __ ] you know you
know what you know what i would think
that she would i would think she would
air on the other side if she was a good
therapist at least because she'd be like
i want this guy to at least feel safe it
was him and i would i thought that too
but no at the gate
wow and meanwhile that woman who i was
dating is the craziest person i've ever
met wow so that
therapist sucked
[Music]